hello and why
gum we're glad you've joined us for this
live webinar understanding cell
reprogramming in treatment resistant
prostate cancer using organoids I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab routes and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning so
let's get started you can post questions
to our speaker during this presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the green Q&A
box at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation also to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problems seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or you
can report any problem by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
good news this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits without
further ado I'd like to now introduce
today's speaker dr. Christine would Oski
dr. Rudovsky completed both a BS and
molecular genetics and a BA in English
with a concentration in theater at the
University of Rochester in 2009
graduating magna [ __ ] wada and Phi Beta
Kappa she immediately began her doctoral
graduate training in pathology at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill defending her dissertation in 2014
her dissertation focused on protein
degradation pathways in cardiac and
skeletal muscle diseases and was funded
by a brief preterm sari pre-doctoral
grant awarded by the American Heart
Association dr. radowski received her
pre-doctoral trainee travel grants from
both the American Society for
investigate
ethology and American Physiological
society to present her dissertation work
at national meetings recently the study
of thyroid hormone signaling and cardiac
growth was awarded a journal award by
the Society of independent a purse by
his journal in 2016 dr. hrabowski began
her postdoctoral training at Roswell
Park Cancer Institute in January 2015 to
study Pro teen digression of a Drennen
receptor one of the factors that drive
treatment resistant prostate cancer she
recently published three comprehensive
review articles on treatment of advanced
prostate cancer and therapy resistance
in September 2016 dr. hrabowski
continued her training in a different
laboratory at Roswell Park Cancer
Institute to study how the loss of tumor
suppressor retinoblastoma rb1 promotes
prostate cancer progression continuing a
project that the lavatory recently
published in science being with a
first-generation student dr. hrabowski
is dedicated to community outreach
especially in teaching young students
with similar backgrounds about
opportunities in stem also known as
science technology engineering and math
in March 2017 she was awarded a
mentorship board by the western New York
stem hub a nonprofit organization
dedicated to k-12 STEM education I'd
like to welcome dr. wood ASCII to begin
her presentation welcome thank you for
such a nice and kind introduction my
name is Kristina madoski and as was
mentioned in my introduction I'm a
postdoctoral research fellow at Roswell
Park Cancer Institute in Buffalo New
York I work on her my mentor dr. David
Goodrich who is also at rajala Park
Cancer Institute as well as our
collaborator who also mentors me from
Dana Farber Cancer Institute in Boston
other than skin cancer prostate cancer
is the most highly diagnosed cancer and
males representing 19 percent of all new
cancer patients
answer diagnosis estimated for 2017 by
the American Cancer Society in males
prostate cancer is the third third
highest cause of cancer-related death at
8% of all estimated cancer-related death
estimated for 2017 some positive news
about prostate cancer however is that 91
percent of all new prostate cancer
diagnoses are patients that have
low-risk disease so these patients have
a disease that will not cause deficit in
the first five years after diagnosis and
that they have nearly a hundred percent
five-year survival rate and live for
many years after their diagnosis however
nine out of a hundred of these patients
who are diagnosed with prostate cancer
are initially diagnosed with advanced
prostate cancer that has spread
elsewhere into the body and for those
patients they only have a 29% five-year
survival rate which means that only 29%
of those patients will be still alive
after five years after their first
diagnosis of prostate cancer or 71% of
those patients who have died as a result
of their cancer after five years while
we study this type of prostate cancer is
currently not curable however it is
treatable and the difference is is that
treatable advanced prostate cancer is
cancer that responds the therapy
in that the disease burden goes down
after therapy and it's to explain this I
have this graph here as you can see
there's disease burden a disease burden
over time and for patients with advanced
prostate cancer they initially have a
first treatment right here at which
point in time almost all patients
respond to this therapy for a short time
but only at about two years and almost
all patients
eventually relapse as you can see here
disease burden will go up yet again and
almost all advanced prostate cancer
patients that have been treated at that
point in time there is a second type of
therapy that we treat at here and that
also decreases disease burden however
disease burden stays low for a less
amount of time after the second
treatment at which point in time disease
burden goes back up yet again and at
this point in time there are no targeted
therapies for these patients
unfortunately these stations can only be
treated with cytotoxic chemotherapy and
our laboratory specifically wants to
find a treatable a pathway to target in
these patients that is targeted for
these particular resistant prostate
cancers as you see there's multiple
rounds of resistance here but to begin
to talk about our findings in our
laboratory I must first to talk about
the what a normal prostate looks like
underneath the microscope so here is a
section of a prostate you can see that
there are these round structures here
these are actually glands so the
prostate is normally functioning as a
way a means to make seminal fluids male
and these glands this is a you can see a
close-up on the right here and these
glands actually produce the proteins
that go into the seminal fluid they're
circular mostly in shape and you can see
with all these different dots here
around the glands that these are
actually cells that produce the proteins
that go into the empty space in the
grand so this is what a normal prostate
will look like however in the low-grade
cancer that I discussed this is actually
a curable cancer where 91% of the
patients as I said before can be cured
of this cancer this is an example of a
low-grade cancer
you can see that there are still glands
for me here you can see that there are
some that are circular but then there
are some that are oblong and some that
have fused together you can see that
there isn't much empty space anymore
there's much less empty space and a lot
of the different cells they're actually
invading into the empty space here and
this is an example of low-grade cancer
that can be treated and can be cured as
an extreme example as you can see and
very much appreciated I hope in advanced
cancer you can see that there seems no
longer to be any circular glands anymore
and this slide right here is actually
very very blue which basically means
that there are many many more cells and
the cells that are packed up right next
to each other there doesn't seem to be a
lot of empty space so those in here
where for perhaps blood vessels are and
there's basically no normal structure
left and this is a type of cancer that's
very likely to become very advanced and
resistant to the treatments that I
discussed before so what we wanted to
study was how tumor suppressors are
related to this resistance and type in
prostate cancer so a tumor suppressor is
a gene that protects the cell from
cancer and when many different studies
have shown that there are several tumor
suppressors and advanced prostate cancer
patients that are lost which means that
when they're lost the cell is going to
become cancerous or has the potential to
become cancerous and so we studied in
our lab is to make a mouse model that
makes prostate cancer this mouse has a
way we have a way in this mouse to
delete different genes specifically in
the prostate so we chose three tumor
suppressor genes and for these tumor
suppressor genes we deleted the first
two tumor suppressor genes and we found
that the prostate cancer that developed
in these mice curable just like the low
risk prostate cancer you see and
however when we deleted the second tumor
suppressor gene we saw that the cancer
would spread throughout the body but it
also it responded the therapy initially
but would come back like I discussed and
in the human prostate cancer patient and
when all three tumor suppressor genes
were deleted we saw that these tumors
are very very aggressive and were
completely resistant to therapy so this
was recently published in the journal
Science and we've been studying these
tumors specifically because this is one
of the first models to be like human
prostate cancer so we can take these
tumors and study how they have developed
to find new ways to treat prostate
cancer for humans and one way that we've
done to study these prostate cancer
tumors is that we've looked at the cells
very very closely underneath the
microscope and so one way that we do
this is that we look boom in on the
cells and then we also stain these cells
with different types of stains for
proteins that will tell us what type of
cells are most likely to be responsive
to therapy so here you can see in the
top this is in the brown is the positive
cells and blue here would be negative so
you can see for the first row many of
the cells are very positive here you see
many brown cells in the second row you
also see positive cells the staining is
a little different it's more lined but
that's the way that this is supposed to
look so these two are positive this
final one is completely negative and
this is for the securable prostate
cancer so we were able to despite this
data we were able to discern that these
cells are responses to therapy and
that's what we saw when we treated these
mice it's a treatment but when we knock
out the second tumor suppressor in
addition to the first one we saw a very
different
pattern so for here you can see that for
the first one there are some cells that
are positive like in when only one tumor
suppressor is deleted
however these other cells here even see
our becoming bluer they're less brown in
the second row you can see very
different staining here there's a lot of
blue cells right here but there's also
very positive clusters of cells that
stain and finally for the third one you
can see that many of these cells are
going from completely blue to a little
bit brown which means that that is going
up but there's also some blue cells
right there too so from this data we can
see that there are some cells that are
responsive some cells that are
non-responsive and that when you delete
both of these tumor suppressors there's
a combination of responsive and
non-responsive cells so finally when we
looked at the tumors from the most
aggressive tumors in this model where
all three tumor suppressors was deleted
we see a very very different scope here
very different so we see here that
almost all of the cells are completely
blue and completely negative for this
first row here the second row the
there's seems to be a similar patchy
pattern however those cells within the
patch seem to be a little less Brown and
finally you can see that for the final
one you can see there's much more brown
and darker Brown here on the edges of
these cells and so do you say to show us
that most of the cells except for a few
we see here are non responsive non
responsive in this tumor which is also
very similar to what we saw when we
treated these tumors they do not respond
so this is one way that we studied on
these tumors to try to understand the
best ways for the best ways to treat
these cancers and to understand the
important pathways that are being
activated so that we can eventually
target them in another way that we also
study these tumors that I don't have
time to talk about right now is to do a
gene expression analysis and one thing
that we found in the aggressive tumors
with two or three tumor suppressors
deleted is that these cells tended to
express genes that are supposed to be
expressed in stem cells so stem cells as
you may know or cells that throughout
development it's a cell that can become
many different cells many different cell
types throughout development and so
eventually these normal cells can also
become cancerous and as I discussed with
you before and prostate cancer will
treat these cancer cells several kinds
and our findings in this data set and in
our paper recently published was that
when there's multiple treatments or when
we have multiple tumor suppressors loss
there seems to be some kind of switch
that happens or reprogramming as
reprogramming as we're calling it where
these cancer cells start expressing stem
cell genes we do not understand how this
is happening as of yet right now but one
thing we do know is that it's associated
with treatment that completely fails in
these cancers so there's something about
becoming more stem like or more like a
stem cells that let these cancer cells
invade therapy so another way that we
are using the method in in the
laboratory in order to do experiments
more quickly is one way that we study
these types of cells and interactions by
cell culture and cell culture is a very
old method this method has been around
for decades and mostly prior to the last
five years or so we would take cancer
cells and grow them flat on the bottom
of the dish so that's called 2d cell
culture
and unfortunately scientists have found
over time that when we grow cells flat
on a dish and to be they don't really
act the same way as when you grow them
in 3d since they originated from a 3d
person and we live in a 3d world so
there's a new method of cell culture
called 3d cell culture and specifically
we're using in the lab prostate organoid
what this method is is that we can take
a tumor from a patient either from the
prostate or and where where the tumors
have spread throughout the patient and
we can take a sample just like a biopsy
and we can break up the cells and
instead of putting it flat on the bottom
of the dish prior instead of putting it
flat on the bottom of the dish like we
did before we combine these cells with a
gel gel like with jello like substance
in liquid form and then drop these gel
substances on the bottom of the dish and
this actually allows the cells to form
structures that they would normally form
in a in a body or in a in Oregon and
these are called prostate organoids or
organoids which means many little organs
and so we can grow these tiny real
organs in the dish from a living patient
and we can eventually hopefully be able
to test different drugs that will be
important for that patient survival and
hopefully that will lead to personalized
medicine down the road but one way that
we're using this method is to try to
understand what's causing these tumor
suppressors the loss of these tumor
suppressors make this prostate cancer so
aggressive and so unable to be treated
this is just an example of an organizer
that eyes and growing in the lab this is
from a mouse tumor and you can see here
that there's webbing here this is
actually an organized that was live so
you can't see the cell but it's growing
here both in all directions is growing
and we're using this method because it
takes about three weeks to grow some
organized in the lab however when we use
a mouse model that can take years to
actually get to a point where there's a
tumor that we can test drugs for for and
so eventually we can use this method to
test many different types of drugs much
faster so they can get to patients and
finally I just like to discuss we're
currently ongoing doing experiments with
the organoid I just wanted to show you a
little bit from a beautiful paper in
cancer cell Blattner at all that was
published earlier this year and this is
a type of experiment that we are doing
so you can see here that these are
organized that they grew and you can see
that they form gland like structures
like I showed you earlier in the
presentation
there's gland like structures here with
cells on the outside and pink protein on
the inside that pink is actually the
protein cells are are purple because
that stains the DNA and you can also use
this you basically cut the organize
imagine that organizers are cut directly
in half and you can see them saying
different things like I showed you
previously when we say in the tumor and
you can also do oh they're beautiful
staining with some fluorescent markers
or you can say many different things at
one time and so we are pursuing many
different avenues using the organize
that eventually we will publish I just
want to show you an example of this so
finally as research is always ongoing I
wanted to show you also that these if
you extract Li examine the organoid
structure compared to the structure of
the glands within the tumor you can see
they're very similar so this model is
very good model to model tumors and
finally I'd like to just discuss a
little
it about the journey to tear and
prostate cancer this image is actually
the details are not important but the
important thing I want to show here is
the length of data the length of time
that so many scientists have been
contributing to the journey to cure for
prostate cancer the data that we have
been all building on actually the first
bounce in 1941 where we found where it
we hiding that find that of where we
found that androgen hormones or
testosterone which is the male hormone
causes prostate cancer to grow and
everything as you can see all these
years discoveries are in red and drugs
drugs are in excuse me discoveries are
in black and drugs are in red you can
see that every year it's building upon
the previous scientists work and I just
feel that as a young scientist I very
much appreciate the amount of work that
has gone before me and the work that I'm
making so that new young scientists can
build upon that nor did help people with
cancer and with that I'd like to
acknowledge my mentor dr. David Goodrich
at Roswell Park Cancer Institute and the
lab members who did most of this work
here and led to the publish of this
paper that we just published in science
talking about these tumor suppressors
chain yuku and Yahoo Ching Wang my co
mentor I'm the co senior author this
paper dr. Lee Ellis at being a Farber
Cancer Institute our collaborators at
Memorial sloan-kettering Cancer Center
dr. Charles Sawyer's and T Union we also
studied one specific gene that's a stem
cell gene they published this also with
our paper earlier this year and of
course our funding from the National
Cancer Institute funding both both my
mentors as well as the Cancer Center
support grant to rouser about cancer
Roswell Park Cancer Institute
and with that I'd like to take any
questions or common thank you